you first met Julian if I'm not mistaken
um when he was fighting sexual assault
charges uh in Sweden and you you
initially joined his his defense team
what made you interested in that case
and what's your perspective on that
whole
case well I joined his legal team in
February 2011 and uh the so Julian had
started publishing the Wikileaks uh
Publications uh from that had been sent
to WikiLeaks by Chelsea Manning in 2010
so a year before I joined his team and
so these Publications from Chelsea
Manning which were uh the collateral
murder video um the Iraq War logs
Afghanistan war
Diaries um diplomatic cables and wantan
Bay files and these are the same
Publications that Julian is indicted
with um indicted over now uh that had
happened uh in in the leadup to um me
joining his legal team and it had also
started uh prior to any preliminary
investigation being opened in Sweden and
actually there were never any charges in
Sweden and none were brought and that's
quite amazing because um it kind of
defies logic right because there was a
big extradition case and um Sweden would
say well we haven't decided whether to
actually bring charges against him but
we just want to question him and then um
there was this question about well why
don't you just question him because in
you know hundreds of other cases uh the
Sweden would travel to other European
countries to question him and so on
anyway that Swedish preliminary
investigation um was uh dropped and
resurrected multiple times it was
dropped four times resurrected three um
no charges were ever brought uh the
it's quite extraordinary I mean the
the
um the amazing thing about this case is
that the prosecutor was refusing to
question him and you think how can it
possibly be that in a in a sex case
where of course memories fade and and it
all depends on you know um the
Recollections of of the people involved
and so on that the prosecutor um had to
be compelled by the Swedish Court of
Appeals
uh six years after the fact um to
question him and uh the reason the court
of appeal compelled her was she said uh
that she had failed her her um
professional duty to um Advance the case
and of course this is just one um aspect
of how that Swedish preliminary
investigation was abusive and the reason
it was abusive was because it was um it
took place in
a highly charged uh political IAL moment
in which Julian was being um actively um
sought by uh authorities because he was
about to publish um the Chelsea mining
leaks he had already published the
collateral murder video and the Afghan
warlocks and then it was one month um
before uh Wikileaks started publishing
the Iraq
warlocks um that he went to Sweden
there's actually a Daily Beast article
uh it's archived it's it's no longer on
the website but it's archived
in which um the US uh the reporter says
that the state department was contacting
its allies in Europe um and urging them
to find a way to stop Julian and his
tracks to arrest him on whatever um
because they had by then they had
arrested uh Chelsea uh Manning then
Bradley Manning um and they knew that
Wikileaks had more major uh leaks coming
out and so they wanted to stop him in
his TR so you're basically saying Sweden
was engaged in a politically motivated
Witch Hunt of Julian but the thing that
I'm also curious about is you know these
are uh not the traditional circumstances
under which most people meet their
spouses um what was this like for you
emotionally was this this sense of I
mean most of the time when you meet
somebody who becomes your husband
they're not you know being accused of
rape uh in another country um how did
you feel signing up to work on this case
and then getting to know Julian like
what was swirling around in your
head well I was um steeped in the in the
um documents surrounding this uh Swedish
preliminary
investigation and um there was no case
to answer from the beginning it was
pretty clear that the uh administrative
use of the extradition uh request from
Sweden uh was a way to uh trap him
basically to to bury him in uh legal um
quagar uh in order to interfere with his
publishing work I mean in Sweden as I
said like the the initial prosecutor who
uh looked at the case said there there
is no um crime of rape involved in these
allegations um but the Swedish um look
the Swedish uh conduct in this case also
responds to uh local
Dynamics uh the the person who took on
the case within days um was also running
for for
um uh there were general elections in
Sweden he was tipped to become the new
uh justice
Minister um Julian's case was in the
media there were a lot of motivations it
wasn't just the uh you know possible
nudge or likely nudge from the state
department at the highest levels uh uh
Julian um Julian's name was was leaked
to the Press uh which should never
happen in the case of a preliminary
investigation where the person hasn't
even be formally accused and as I said
he was never formally accused in those
nine years um the un's uh working group
on arbitrary detention which looked at
this case from 2014 onwards um
saw uh the um underlying investigation
material it was an adversarial process
in which Sweden and the UK um also
participated and were unsuccessful in
convincing this um group of un experts
on arbitrary detention um that they had
conducted themselves in a lawful manner
they had in fact violated International
obligations concerning arbitrary
detention when it came to Julian because
as I said he was neither convicted or
even charged in relation to Sweden um
and so it was this extraordinary abuse
of nature of the Swedish allegations um
that was immediately obvious to me as uh
a member of his legal legal team but
also as a Swedish speaker because I'm
fluent in Swedish and so I could
directly access the um um the material
of the case uh that we had access to to
see that this was absurd and my own
experience I mean as I got to know
Julian was to see how he was uh
persecuted and um maligned in all sorts
of ways of course the Swedish aspect was
just one it was an effective one because
uh Julian had a lot of support from the
left uh initially um because these
Publications concerned of course the
bush Wars and so on and a sex case um
even one without a formal accusation or
a conviction or anything uh obviously is
going to alienate
um a portion of the left um and and uh a
big portion of women um and there was a
deliberate uh strategy as as these uh
foyer documents show hey thanks for
watching that clip from our new show
just asking questions you can watch
another clip here or the full episode
here new episodes drop every week so
subscribe to reent TV's YouTube channel
to get notified when that happens or to
the just asking questions podcast on
Apple Spotify or any other podcatcher
see you next week